we bring in the Dodgers manager Dave
Roberts joining us Continental Tire
Coaches Corner
good morning skip house Milwaukee Oh Dan
got in last night I got a nice little
dinner and got some grain but it's well
that was a good little statute
throughout there yeah but what happened
when we had you on you know everybody's
questioning you and this team and
underachieving
how would you explain what happened
since then I I did your show I guess
right now Oh mojo the Dan Patrick mojo
just flip the script will I get a
playoff share of Davis if you dodge OU's
make the playoffs do I get a playoff
share I'm gonna talk to Clayton and
Justin Turner and then we'll see if we
work right awesome I appreciate it
you were saying what happened with this
team no you know what I just think we
just started winning baseball games and
I mean everything kind of up to the game
the preparation everything and obviously
we had some guys banged up
I think JT was a big part of it getting
him back to health
outside of that guys just started
playing better and I don't know if it
was a night you know you always never
want to say World Series hangover
because I don't think that that affect
us I really felt we just didn't get off
to a good start and we started playing
better baseball the coolest moment
managing the all-star game is one Wow
being on the line getting introduced and
shaking hands with the best players in a
game and having an opportunity to shake
hands with the veterans in it and the
infield right after yeah did you know at
the time that Manny Machado was going to
be a Dodger I did not I was hopeful you
know obviously I heard what everyone
else was here and listen to what people
said the worst kept secret so our guys
were working on it but I was hopeful but
it wasn't done so I was hopeful did you
walk oh did you say hello to Manny
Machado
so I saw him the day we got in and it
was an awkward kind of hello and
excitement it was kind of one of those
things that you're supposed to be dating
but you're not supposed to be dating
kind of a it was weird but yeah well
yeah okay but how involved are you when
it comes to something like this well
it's more of hey do you think manikin
out partying yes that's not a tough
question there to answer with our ball
club now we're gonna work them in does
it make sense
other players we dig another character
by something like that that's pretty
much a no-brainer what do you think of
miking players during a game in the
outfield as we solder in the all-star
game you know what I actually things
have evolved in our world and in
baseball obviously in sports and I think
it's great I'm old school but I think
that a way now when you're talking about
getting interest of fans so I think does
the real-time interaction right here and
what's going on during a game I think
it's I think it's great because I don't
think that will affect outfielders
ability to go make a play once the
pitches deliver yeah I don't like when
the managers are interviewed during the
game I don't really get much out of it
how do you feel about the right in-game
interview I'm with you and I think it's
just trying to get it again the fan
closer to the dugout but I've done it a
few times and it's more of trying to do
I love it absolutely not do I like it no
but I think that I understand the bigger
picture so that's why I try to I guess
do my part but I can kind of appreciate
your thoughts yeah yeah I I don't know
if I like I liked it in the all-star
game but I don't know if all of a sudden
you know Matt Kemp is going to be miked
every
home game here or how he would feel
about doing something like that or you
know can I put it on positional players
could I could the catcher be miked up I
don't know it you know we're trying to
make the experience better for people
whether they're at the game or they're
watching on TV but I like I'm just
worried it's sort of like interleague
play you're gonna have too much of it
and then it loses the novelty there I
just think the thing is that the reality
and maybe it's unfortunate is that you
are as a minority in the sense of you're
a baseball purist yo you'll watch the
game to watch the game you don't need
any is that the outside noise internal
noise I guess now literally but I think
that to keep the different type of humor
to get their attention I think that
that's kind of what does it but you're
you're the minority he's Dave Roberts
Dodger manager joining us Continental
Tire Coaches Corner
when you look at the second half of this
season I count how do you sort of divvy
up the second instead of looking at it
in you know in its entirety or do you
look at week by week or month by month
two weeks you know in two weeks out you
know what it's a little layer with the
pitching it's sort of a 10 day outlook
and I think that with the positional
player it's like a seven day outlook
trying to make sure I can look at the
problem holes and make sure I get a
rotation get guys involved but I think
that as a whole I think and this is the
truth our guys do a very good job of the
day-to-day and last year come November
1st 2nd game 7 of the World Series
we still had gas tank to keep going and
I think that's the challenge for any
ball club when you're playing a long
season of baseball where you're not
trying to get too far ahead so the
pitching part you have to do the
positional player I think a manager has
to tenant the communication with the
player but I think that day to day I'm
just trying to win one baseball game at
a time and then preset to do it again
and again again that's the challenge can
you have too much starting pitching I
read where you're looking at a six-man
rotation
I don't think so I will say this is that
I don't think that you can add too much
started fishing but it takes up buying
for the guys so as we break for 17
straight days each guys gonna get an
extra day so obviously pitchers are used
to the five day routine so you know
keeping them in the rotation not sending
a guy to the bullpen understand that an
extra day is a good thing so that buying
is absolutely necessary as LeBron been
to a baseball game yet not yet but it's
magic doesn't get him to a baseball game
he only get back home off the 17 day
road trip he might get a call from me
but did you see Shaq take BP no no we
got recently well it was you know I
think it was a softball so a slow pitch
softball that he took BP so I'm sure
he's got a bad swipe how was it what do
we got on the scout no 22 8 and what do
you do no I'm in he's got a lot of holes
he's got a lot of holes in it swing
ahold oh my gosh yeah makes big strike
zone
Dave big strike zone there yeah whoo
yeah the electrics right the electronic
strikes not work you know I'm sure did
you uh who's the athlete in another
sport that you think could have been
graded baseball that you you knew ran
into from another sport gosh off the top
of my head you know I guess the Stafford
I think that I mean that's just I
thought they're gonna get first all they
were high school teammates good there's
baseball is it tough until this this
Tebow thing is really intriguing me I
heard his hand recently some sort of
following the Tebow story and tracking
him in rooting form
baseball is a tough game though I mean
Michael the greatest athlete of all time
did it and really struggled but it just
shows how difficult this game is his
Tebow
better baseball player than Michael
Jordan yes yes okay
all right did you did you see Jordan
play I just saw the video I kind of like
he was at Birmingham so I was younger
but certain guys that I knew played with
them in Birmingham for the parents so I
missed them I just saw essentially what
the American populations on TV yeah but
when you comes to baseball you know I
don't know what here's Jordan you know
one of the great athletes in the world
why didn't that translate to baseball
his swing was long you know there wasn't
quickness in there but you saw that
there there was talent there it just it
didn't translate yeah I think the age
was part of it I don't recall what year
he did it but I think the age his age
was a part of it and I think the long
levers is another part of it yeah it's
kind of fascinating though I mean I give
Tebow a whole lot of credit Dave to do
this and and you know if you're
successful three out of ten times you're
an all-star you know you're not even
succeeding at that and willing to do
that at his age is is pretty remarkable
yeah his age and what he's accomplished
to go back and get back into the bushes
and go through the grind and I said I
mean that and I did it as a 21 to 26
year old and I was brutal so to see what
he's accomplished and go to through the
grind are very commendable
what's the oddest thing that you saw in
the minor leagues oh yeah we can't talk
about that on the air oh I'm gonna tell
jokes okay you know I think the oddest
thing is the locker room being like a
trailer you know you get off a 12 hour
bus ride you show up to a clubhouse
which is a trailer in right field and
everyone's in there changing
that's odd the things in between the
inning the gimmicky things are just to
kind of keep that interest but but
actually and all this stuff is like
those are some of the best memories and
I could go on then but those are some of
the best memories I had as a
professional ball player you're you were
in what 27 when you got called up I was
27 yes sir what was that what was that
day like it was in Rochester New York
playing for the Buffalo Bisons planning
as Rochester Red Wings the Baltimore
affiliate at the time with my wife at
the time get the call from Eric Wedge
the manager go to his room come back to
my room
tell my wife were jumping on the bed
like three-year-olds and then you're
making a call back West it's all of our
family and trying to get slice to go to
Tampa to meet the team in Tampa and
didn't sleep a whole lot that day was
top of the order for the Indians and
Kenny Kenny loften was on the DL but
Omar Vizquel hid behind me Robbie Alomar
hid behind me Jim told me David Justice
I mean it was absolutely insane man that
was a great lineup great line him it was
a great line yeah and you know it's
funny is so I told my son the other day
at the Home Run Derby Bobby with junior
won the home on amateur home run contest
that they had this little thing at the
Derby and my first major league hit was
against his father so that sort of aged
me yeah oh man what were you making in
the minor leagues at the time my first
paycheck okay my first paycheck was 353
after taxes I was in Jamestown New York
and then at that point in time I was in
triple-a and I think I was probably
making maybe 20 2,200 2,100 a month and
that's paid over only five months of the
year no boy did you work in a batting
cage after during the offseason did your
wife ever say you know what maybe we
give this up
she did not so she she did not and then
and there was a breaking point at one
point in time I was feeling sorry for
myself one time when I got sent back to
high a and when I was at the Tigers I
called my dad and he gave me a no
sympathy as a 30 year military as that
said if you want to play play if you
don't come home and so that was kind of
it the tough love and I decided to keep
planning keep fighting and fortunately
it worked out good to talk to you I did
turn around for you and have fun with
the Brewers coming up tonight we
appreciate it as always David DP you the
man thank you buddy maybe one of these
days someone I'm in I'm in some red wine
you and I will break bread increase some
great great red wine yeah you kind of
big-time me at the all-star game I was I
was there for BP and you know
Kenley said yeah yeah apparently because
you were you know you were surrounded by
you know people hanger-ons talk to me
and tell me the Machado news I think
that's what it was you were trying to
hide from because you knew that you had
especially after a bottle of wine I
would have been able to ask you so
Machado is you're gonna keep the same
number yeah yeah we're giving prospects
Dan thanks for asking all right thank
you Dave so Dave Robert sees cotton
entire Coaches Corner
Dodgers manager they got Brewers coming
up tonight first place the nationally
glass I always love talking to them cuz
I feel like if I do sit down have dinner
with him that's what the conversation is
gonna be like four more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]